all right it's sunday night
or monday morning depending on how long
it takes me to edit this regardless we
have a new episode of house of the
dragon and that is the fantasy series
that keeps me coming back for more every
week it's been three years since the
previous episode king viserys now has a
new son named aegon targaryen for the
past couple years ranera targaryen's
been you know pissed so she's like my
dad named me the heir but i'm pretty
sure when he has a son um that'll go
away and everyone's like renera you're
of age now you need to get married she's
like i don't want to get married and her
father the king's like it's tradition
you need to get married i want to know
that you're taken care of and she's like
i don't like the other suitors i like
this low-born dude
you ever seen the movie aladdin writer
her love story in this show is pretty
much jasmine's story in aladdin this
time jump was intense man it wasn't the
few months between the first and second
episode three years damon targaryen's
been fighting a bad case of crab feeder
for three years we haven't really seen
any of it kind of makes the crab feeder
guy feel like he's just he's there to
give damon targaryen something to do
because he's here and then he's done
he's gone and well that's that also none
of that's nearly as interesting as otto
hightower's scheming you know the
father-daughter dynamic this king
feeling emotionally torn between his
duty and his daughter and he definitely
does feel like he's being worn down to
the emotional nub but it is always
pretty bossy and dragons burned people
up and that one dragon stepped on that
dude's like yeah save us all i was like
you're gonna die in three two
on cue we see a lannister in 200 years
before the events of game of thrones
lannisters show us that lannisters are
just
always lannisters he's all like hear
your grace here's this really gaudy
spirit i made for you you know just in
case you want to kill the stag with it
it'd be awesome we have no instagram but
i can take mental pictures
looked awesome what i liked most about
this episode is king viserys you're like
is he not naming his new son young aegon
his new heir the whole thing ronero's
been stewing about for a couple years
and you're like i he doesn't look like
he's going to then he has that straight
up conversation with her he's like i'm
not gonna do that dude like you you just
you've been assuming all this time i
give her a pass she's young why didn't
this dude come to her and be like why
are you broody for the past couple years
oh you think i'm gonna no i'm not going
to communication the key to diffusing
most tension
cheers to wasted father-daughter time in
the land of westeros where the average
lifespan is
19. that might be gracious the average
might actually be closer to 10. you know
what i do like about king viserys though
is he is the peak behind the curtain you
usually see kings and royalty and people
in his position
in stories and shows movies like this
but you see their actions and what they
do in these policies and you're like oh
what a dick i like the moments like when
he was in front of the bonfire he's all
shit-faced spilling his guts i like
moments like that with him
where you can see the peak behind the
curtain of this person
behind the policies that he's throwing
out there you know behind the traditions
and how he's really he feels torn about
all of it this really shows how this guy
feels torn between his duty to his
country and his loyalty to his daughter
the last rush of damon targaryen that
was intense because this is a story
it being westeros and me never reading
the books there are characters i'm like
i don't know they could die tomorrow
they could live forever i don't know so
when damon targaryen was running he was
making that rush to kill that case of
crab feeder that's plagued him for three
years i was like he might die which was
a pretty bossy and king viserys was like
hey you're my brother i care i know
you've been itching something really
fierce over there i'm gonna send a fleet
to help you cure that case of crab
feeder you've had for the past three
years over my dead deck and just goes
running into battle it's three arrows
not quite the boromir but you know
he takes some damage dude did not want
his brother's help new dragon came out
of nowhere and saved his ass though but
then he just runs into a cave and you
see someone carrying something you're
like oh it's half the crab feeder's body
so he's dead now i would have liked to
have seen the carnage the evisceration
the fatality you know the mortal kombat
fan in me give me the blood
give me the salsa so at the end of last
week's episode i did what i usually
don't do which is watch the whole next
week on house of the dragon thing at the
end i didn't watch it this week so the
time jump might be two days it might be
27 years i wouldn't know but the time
jumps are a bit intense in this show it
really does give a kind of a disjointed
feeling i get it they're trying to cover
a lot of ground really quickly you know
i gotta say king viserys is a far more
complex character than i thought he was
going to be after the pilot episode i
feel like this episode just upped the
complexity for him and his relationship
with renera all right so house of the
dragon episode 3 have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you